in the 1980s buddy cop movies are as
common as comic book movies have become
today and while the theme of hardened
officers solving a crime or navigating
their platonic relationship was repeated
many times including in Beverly Hills
Cop Dragnet and Tango and cash one
franchise perfected the sub-genre Lethal
Weapon starring Mel Gibson Danny Glover
and their formidable on-screen chemistry
the first Lethal Weapon film released in
1987 quickly became the quintessential
buddy cop movie featuring humor action
A-list movie stars and the famous line
I'm too old for this
the first movie is considered one of the
best action movies of the era
unsurprisingly the magic was recreated
two years later with Lethal Weapon 2
becoming one of the top grossing movies
released in a year that features
celebrated sequels like Ghostbusters 2
Back to the Future 2 and Indiana Jones
and the Last Crusade Gibson and Glover
continued their on and off-screen
friendship completing four Lethal Weapon
movies by 1998.